.
Perhaps you know that any equation is linear
You can write y = mx + b
Where m is the line inclination
The same tendency we were dealing with
In previous presentations
Height / After Line
Or it's a regression line
And b is the y intersection
Intersection y
I think it's easy to verify that b is
The verification method is offset x = 0
If you get x = 0 - remember that x = 0, this is
I mean where the intersection with y axis
If x = 0, this equation becomes y =
m × 0 + b
m × 0 = 0
I will not pay attention to the value of m
Then y will equal b
If point 0, b will be on this line
0, b
The line will intersect with the y axis at the point
y = b
We'll see that using actual numbers in
Upcoming offers
So prove to you that M is the inclination, let 's
Try with some setup
We know that point 0, b falls on the line
What happens when x = 1?
When x = 1
We will get y = m × 1
Or it is equal to m + b
We also know that point 1, m + b
Also located on line
Right?
This is the value of y
What is the tendency between that point and that point?
Let's take this as an end point, if we have m + b
Change in y, m + b - b / change in x
I / 1 - 0
This is the change in y / variance in x
We use two points
That's the end point
That is the starting point
If you simplify it, b - b = 0
1 - 0 = 1
We get m / 1, which equals m
I hope you are satisfied now and I did not bother you
Select it by using all of these
Variables here
But it will give us the inclination of this doubt
The intersection will be y
Now, what I want to do in this exercise is to look at
These graphs are then used in finding
The equation
We'll look at this, we'll find the inclination
We find the y intersection and then we know the equation
Let's start with Line A. What is A Mile?
Let's start with a random point
Let's start from here
We want to get even numbers
If we move to 1, 2, 3
If delta x = 3
is not it?
1, 2, 3
Delta y - I do this because I want to get
The number is even here - Delta y = - We go
Down by 2-- = -2
For A, the change in y for the change in x
When the change in x = 3, the change in y = -2
If the tilt is 2 / 3-
When we move to the top by 3, we will move down by 2
Or if we move to the top by 1, we will move down by 2/3
We can not see this here exactly, but you undoubtedly see it
When you move to the top by 3
This is the tendency
We have done half of this
Now we find the intersection y
This m
Now what the value of b
Any intersection y
Well, which intersects this with y axis?
Well, we've already said that the tilt is 2/3
If this point y = 2
When we move to the top by 1, it can
We move down by 2/3
If this point should be 1 1/3
Or in another way, we can say it is 4/3
That point is y = 4/3
Here
More than a little
1 1/3 approx
It can be said that b = 4/3
We will know that the equation is y = m
2/3, x + b, ie + 4/3
This is equation A
Let us find equation B
I hope we do not deal with
Many fractions are here
Equation B
Let us first find its inclination. Let's start when
A certain point
We can start at this point
Let me here
B
Equation B
When delta x = - call me type
In this way, delta x
If delta x is 1
When we move 1 to the right, what will happen
For y delta?
We move to the top by 3
Delta x
Delta y
The change in y is 3
If delta y / delta x, when we go to the right
The change in x is 1
The change in y is positive 3
If inclination = 3
What is y intersection?
Well, when x = 0, y = 1
If b = 1
This was somewhat easier
The equation here is y = 3x + 1
Let's do the last line
Line C, let's find the intersection y first. As you see
The intersection of y - when x = 0, the y =
If b = -2
What is the tendency?
m = change in y / change in x
Let's start at the intersection of y
If we go to the right by 1, 2, 3, 4
If the change in x = 4
What is the change in y?
The change in y is -2
If the change in y is -2 when the change in x = 4
If mileage = 1/2, 2,4
The equation here is y = 1 / 2x, that is
Inclination
We're done
Now let's move on to the other direction
Let 's look at some equations of lines and know that this
The slope and this intersection y - so m
And that b - let's represent them graphically
Let's start with this line first
I have already begun to cover it with orange
The intersection of y is 5
When x = 0, y = 5
You can check it out in the equation
When x = 0, y = 1, 2, 3
4, 5
This is the y intersection and the inclination is 2
This means that when I move 1 by x, I will move up by 2
Towards y
If you move to 1 towards x, I will move up by 2
If it turns back to 1 towards x, it will move down by 2
Towards y
If you turn back to 1 in the x direction, you will move down by 2
I will continue to do so
If this line looks like - I can not draw lines in style
Very well done, but it will be the best I can do
It will look like this
I will continue more and more
This is the first line
I can keep going down that way
Let's draw this line
y = -0.2x + 7
Let me type this, y = -0.2x + 7
It's always easy to think about fractions
If 0.2 equals 1/5
We can write y = -1 / 5x + 7
We know that the intersection of y is 7
That is, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
This is the intersection of y when x = 0
This shows that for every 5 we move to the right
We will move down by 1
We can consider it 1 / 5-
Delta y / delta x = -1.5
For every 5 we move to the right, we will move 1 down
Per 5 if
1, 2, 3, 4, 5
Move 5 to the right
This means that we have to move down by 1
1, 2, 3, 4, 5
We have to move 1 down
If we return, that is if we move by 5 back - instead of
This, if I consider it 1/5
These are clearly in equal numbers
If we return 5 - this - 5
1, 2, 3, 4, 5
So we will move 1 to the top
If we return 5-1, 2, 3, 4
5 - We will move to the top by 1
If the line looks like this
Just get out the points
I think you absorbed the idea
I just have to get those points out
I can not draw it a little straight
Now let's draw this, y = -x
y = -x
Where is the phrase b?
I do not see any words for b
You remember that we said that y = mx + b
Where b?
Well, b = 0
You can consider it
Here is b = 0
When x = 0, y = 0
This is the intersection of y, here on the origin point
Then tilt - another time we'll see a negative signal
You can consider it 1x + 0-
If the inclination is -1
When we move to the right by 1, when the change in x is 1
The change in y is -1
When we move upwards by 1 on x, we will move down by 1 on y
Or if you move down 1 by x, it will move up by 1
y, where x and y have opposite signals
They move in opposite directions
If the line looks like this
You can imagine he divides
Second and fourth quarters
Now I will solve another issue
Let's solve this
y = 3.75
Perhaps you are saying now, we will look to y
= mx + b
Any phrase x?
It does not exist
Well, really here, the equation can be rewritten to become y
= 0x + 3.75
Now it has become logical
The tilt is 0
It does not matter how much x is changed, where y does not change
Delta y / delta x = 0
I do not care about the amount of change in x
Where the intersection of y is 3.75
If 1, 2, 3.75 are located here
You have to approach them
3 3/4
Whatever the change in x, y will not change, where y
It will always be 3.75
The line will be horizontally on
y = 3.75
Anyway, I hope you found this useful
.